دعني أضغط عليك بشأن ما الذي ستفعله
ألمانيا في هذه المرحلة لأنها
تلقت برلين بعض
الانتقادات مؤخرًا بسبب
موقفها من عدم الرغبة في تقديم
مساعدة عسكرية في شكل
أسلحة ، على سبيل المثال لأوكرانيا ،
كيف تصف موقف ألمانيا؟
في هذه المرحلة وهل تعتقد أنها
بحاجة إلى تقديم
المزيد من
الدعم ، فمن الأفضل أن يُنظر إلى
التنسيق مع الحلفاء الأوروبيين الآخرين
وتقديم المزيد من
الدعم لأوكرانيا خلال كل هذه
النظرة ،
يجب أن أقول هذا أه عندما
نتحدث عن إمكانية  للحرب في
أوكرانيا علينا أن نفهم بشكل خاص
أولئك الموجودين
في أوروبا أو في الغرب الأوسع
أنها ليست الحرب ضد أوكرانيا إنها
ليست مجرد حرب ضد أوكرانيا إنها
أه ستخاض
حرب أوروبا
في أوكرانيا إذا كانت ستبدأ إذا
بدأت  لذلك أعتقد أنه من مصلحة كل
دولة دعم أوكرانيا
التي يمكنها محاربة
الغزو المحتمل الذي أه
سيخوض على حدودنا
بشكل أساسي على  أوروبية على حدود أوروبية
أه الحكومة الألمانية مازالت حكومة جديدة نوعا ما
ومع أه
إه وحاولت أن تستمر أه
إرث قرابة 16 عاما من الحكومة الماضية
لذا أعتقد ذلك لكن
الحقيقة
التي أخذت أه
أن الجديد الجديد  الحكومة التي
رحبت بالإله الجديد مختلفة تمامًا
عما واجهته ألمانيا خلال الـ
16 عامًا الماضية ، ولم يعد الاستقرار
موجودًا ، حيث يتغير العالم بسرعة كبيرة
، وبالتالي أعتقد أن
الحكومة الألمانية الجديدة تتكيف
مع الواقع الجديد